[Musica]
avete mai pensato a tutto ciò che è
nella nostra testa
le nostre idee tutto quello che ci ruota
davvero dentro i pensieri che abbiamo
ogni giorno
bene la maggior parte di queste idee non
sono nostre
la maggior parte di queste idee sono dei
palazzi che noi abbiamo che non
provengono dalla nostra esperienza di
vita ma arrivano da ciò che ci è stato
raccontato dagli altri e vi dirò di più
non sono nemmeno paure
bene le sovrastrutture mentali sono dei
processi
velocissime che rimbalzano tra mente
razionale ed inconscio immaginatevi un
po una pallina di flipper quindi una
pallina che va avanti indietro avanti
indietro
si manifestano per farvi un esempio ogni
qualvolta che vogliamo comprare qualcosa
pensateci a me succede spesso ogni volta
che noi vogliamo comprare qualcosa
mettiamo in atto una parte razionale ed
una parte emotiva le faccio un esempio a
voglio comprare qualcosa voglio comprare
questo vestito perché mi sta bene e poi
perché è da tempo che non compro
qualcosa e potrei continuare
all'infinito con questo tipo di frasi
che voi avrete già sentito migliaia di
volte bene o male sono le stesse che
diciamo tutti però c'è un problema se
noi parlassimo di lavoro che cosa
cambierebbe
oggi lavoro è l'argomento più gettonato
ai pranzi di famiglia alle rimpatriate
scolastiche
croce e delizia davanti ad un caffè con
un'amica e anche diciamolo motivo di
esodo per la maggior parte dei giovani
parametro di giudizio per inquadrare
qualcuno ecco questo è il nocciolo della
prima questione parametro di giudizio
per inquadrare 1 avete capito bene
ora vi racconta un'esperienza che mi è
successa la prima volta che io arrivai a
milano per un colloquio di lavoro
ero tra gelatissima perché allora ero
alla mia prima esperienza
neolaureata
partivo da un paese piccolissimo e la
prima cosa che mi arcade appena arrivai
su incontrare una ragazza che poi
divenne una mia amica che mi chiese ma
tu di cosa ti occupi
beh io provai una sensazione di disagio
a quei tempi non avevo neanche una casa
ero davvero agli inizi quella sensazione
di disagio mi rimase dentro perché io mi
sentii giudicata
l'emozione del disagio era un giudizio
quante volte ci capita di sentirsi
giudicati e di giudicare in base al
lavoro che svolgiamo
bene noi viviamo in una società dove
siamo definiti dal nostro lavoro nella
quale noi studiamo ci formiamo ci
muoviamo in base al nostro lavoro
e come è successo a me
conosciamo una persona e la prima
domanda che poniamo riguarda il lavoro
niente da fare più forti di noi
noi vogliamo inquadrare subito che
abbiamo davanti
pretendiamo di conoscere qualcuno in
base a quello che fa non in base a
quello che è
e questi purtroppo sono dei concetti che
ci hanno inculcato da bambini e non sono
completamente veri pensate a frasi anche
che abbiamo sentito tutti
prima il dovere e poi il piacere
ossia lavora e poi divertiti quindi
tradotto sarebbe come dire un po il
lavoro è noioso oppure dall'altra parte
fai quello che ami e non lavorerà in un
solo giorno della tua vita
tutto questo è vero ma secondo me è
riduttivo
sembra quasi che lavorare sia o la cosa
più orribile del mondo o la cosa più
piacevole del mondo
inoltre a mare un lavoro non vuol dire
per forza avere la stessa identità
fondersi essere la stessa cosa rispetto
a quello che si fa quindi ragionando su
questi temi la cosa importante è che noi
non dovremmo mai
sottovalutare che siamo noi a fare quel
lavoro
siamo noi che con la nostra forza con la
nostra competenza con la nostra voglia
riusciamo a dare un'identità a quel
lavoro altrimenti sarebbe sarebbe tutto
inutile ma allora perché è così
importante
conoscere il lavoro della persona che
abbiamo di fronte del nostro
interlocutore
ecco adesso
scegliamoli un altro gradino in questa
scala che ci porta a conoscere le nostre
ombre
beh il tema è soldi
sapere che lavoro fa una persona ci dà
più o meno un'idea di quanto guadagna
ora qualcuno di voi giustamente potrà
anche dire beh laura ma senza senza
guadagnare non si vive ok d'accordo vero
non del tutto vero
lentamente la nostra cultura la nostra
società ci hanno inculcato che il
benessere e la nostra felicità
dipendono esclusivamente dal denaro
sembrerebbe quasi che se hai soldi vivi
bene se non li hai no quindi la nostra
esistenza è indissolubilmente legata al
denaro e all'importanza che viviamo
ecco se non lo avete notato la nostra
società è diventata davvero ostile sotto
certi versi
quindi anche quando abbiamo quel lavoro
che tanto volevamo per il quale abbiamo
studiato una vita ci siamo prodigati beh
allora non siamo ancora felici bene cosa
ci manca
ci manca che noi ad oggi abbiamo
monetizzato tutto noi abbiamo
monetizzato le relazioni professionali
il nostro network
noi ci muoviamo in una disarmonica danza
del dare avere dare avere che però non è
così profittevole come potremmo pensare
cosa ci toglie questa danza questa danza
ci toglie la venta ci toglie
l'autenticità ci toglie la libertà di
fare quello che avremmo fatto senza
pensare al ritorno
ora ragionate un attimo su quanto
sarebbe bello
potersi comportare senza un vincolo di
ritorno
decido di fare qualcosa senza aspettarmi
niente ma solo per il piacere di farla
ora qualcuno potrà dire io che cosa ci
guadagna oppure che fine ci facciamo
fare a tutti i training elevare langhe
di corsi su come costruirsi un network
portatori di interesse bene io non sto
qui a dirvi che questi corsi vanno
accantonati noi possiamo prendere quello
che c'è di buono
ma far fare un click al nostro cervello
e alla nostra anima
dovremo allenarci
all'autenticità alla possibilità di
poterci comportare
ragionando fuori dalle logiche di
ritorno economico
allora io vi racconto quello che ho
fatto nel mio piccolo io nel mio piccolo
ho pensato di creare uno spazio quindi
un blog nel quale le persone le aziende
che decidono di poter fare sharing di
poter condividere le loro idee di valori
possano farlo così senza logiche di
ritorno ognuno mette a disposizione la
propria esperienza per l'altro per
generare valore
io ho posto luce sulla mia ombra lo
illuminata come si fa con una torcia per
per avere un valore per mettere a
disposizione degli altri quel valore che
io ho sperimentato su di me quindi oggi
quello che mi preme trasmettervi a
questo
cerchiamo di
ritagliarci un momento nostro un momento
anche di intimità con noi stessi nel
quale ci riconosciamo con quello che
siamo davvero quindi liberi dalle
logiche di business da quello che
dovremmo fare pensando ad un ritorno
futuro che forse ci sarà o forse no
riconnettendosi con noi stessi pensando
alla logica del qui ed ora
cercando di pensare al valore che noi
possiamo dare agli altri
svincolato da tutto
quindi che cosa oggi posso fare io per
gli altri per aumentare questo valore
per metterlo a disposizione
bene io penso che se noi riuscissimo
ognuno nel nostro piccolo in base anche
a quello che può fare ok
io penso che in quel momento solo così
forse potremmo sperimentare davvero la
reciprocità vi ringrazio
[Applauso]
[Musica]